yesterday we had a nearly 14 hour live
stream of the second day of joe biden's
supreme court nominee judge katanji
brown jackson's
confirmation hearing during which she
was asked about 30 minutes of questions
by each
of the full group is 22 senators on the
judiciary committee i believe they got
to 20 and then the last two were going
to go this morning and we're going to
get to some clips of what was asked and
we're going to talk about all of that
but before doing any of that i think
it's important to take an objective look
at
how qualified judge jackson is and by
any any any measure
any objective measure
judge katanji brown jackson
is
or would be
one of the most qualified supreme court
justices in recent history and this is
not going by
uh vague
ideology-based opinions or anything
subjective merely looking at the facts
of her experience
it is hard to find a more qualified
supreme court justice recently now i
know many of you as we get into this are
going to say but hold on a second david
if amy coney barrett can be on the court
if kavanaugh can be on the court why is
this even a conversation and of course
you would be completely correct to frame
it in those terms
but because it is worth actually
thinking about the experience of a
potential supreme court justice we're
going to look at it and there's a very
good chart out which looks at the res
the current justices and compares judge
jackson's experience and what you find
when you look at it is that she checks
more boxes than do any of the justices
currently on the court
when you look at
whether she went to an ivy league law
school which i don't think is the the
standard by which we should evaluate
qualifications but one of the things
that many say is well where where was
the legal education
all of the justices currently on the
court other than barrett went to an ivy
league law school and so did judge
jackson
when you look at which justices were
clerks on the supreme court clarence
thomas alito and sotomayor were not the
other uh justices on the court were and
judge jackson was a supreme court clerk
great in terms of who was a public
defender none of them none of them judge
jackson actually brings unique
experience or would bring unique
experience to the court by virtue of
having been a public defender none of
the nine current justices did that as a
job
um only justice breyer
who would be
replaced by judge jackson
was on a sentencing commission and
indeed judge katanji brown jackson was
on a sentencing commission only judge
sotomayor of the justices currently on
the court was a district judge
judge jackson has that experience in her
background as well
and currently all justices other than
elena kagan
were judges on courts of appeals
and indeed
judge jackson was a judge
on the court of appeals now i so so the
objective case is
as or more qualified
than any of the justices currently on
the court now i think there's one
interesting thing to talk about here um
you and i might look at the experience
of judge jackson and say wow that's
that's amazing and it's actually
fascinating that public defender
experience
and sentencing commission experience and
district judge experience that's unique
that's a unique level of experience
nobody on the court right now has had
experience in those three areas but
there's a liability that comes with that
which we learned about yesterday during
the hearing
and it is that it provides a significant
amount of fodder
for which she can be attacked well why
did you do this specific sentence in
this case
or why did you rule in this particular
way why did you defend this particular
client even though lawyers defend
clients that's what they do and the
analogy here would be imagine that i ran
for something
you and i might say well you know what's
what's great is i have over 10 years of
talking about so many different issues
you can just kind of look up and see
what my thoughts are but the truth is
that if you did
let's call it
a political colonoscopy or you know a
political body cavity search and you
went through everything i've ever said
on the show you know hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of hours you would
without a doubt be able to find things
that don't represent number one the what
i would call the best of my show
that might be opinions which have
changed because either
my opinions have changed or there's
different information that has now come
out which has led me to have to revise
opinions so without a doubt if i were to
run for something
although i see it as a positive thing
that i have this long track record of
people being able to see the evolution
of my views you would be able to troll
that and find things to take out of
context or isolate that i without a
doubt would make me look bad i'm i
it would make me look bad and along the
same way although you and i might say
wow public defender experience and
sentencing commission experience and
district judge experience that's
unbelievable what we saw yesterday
during the first day of questions asked
to judge jackson
and what we are already seeing today
during the second day of questions which
is underway right now as we are at as we
are recording today's show is that it
also can serve as
a sort of catalyst or as a basis
to focus in extraordinarily narrowly
uh on particular decisions and take them
out of context and and whatever else one
other thing um there was a lot of uh
concern yesterday from republican
senators about
sentences given by judge jackson on what
now i want to be clear some people call
it child porn i don't think that's the
right word
because pornography
is almost always legal and involving
consenting adults and is a business to
some degree
to just put child on that and to pretend
it what we're talking about is
child exploitation right i mean we're
not talking about filmmakers when we
talk about people
producing or or whatever the these
images but for what they call child porn
which i don't think is the right term
for it they talked a lot about her
departures from
the maximum penalties as sort of a
liability but the truth is the people
doing that like for example republican
senator josh hawley he has previously
supported many judicial candidates uh
that
departed from the maximum sentencing
numerous times so they focused in on
that
uh but significant hypocrisy there so
that's the qualifications net let's now
go to some of the questioning